[Music]
[Applause]
luna the fastest easiest way to buy
bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's
the perfect place to start
[Music]
hey guys and welcome back to the
show of course it is empowered by icon
plus
capital the vc company so matthew
welcome to the show how are you pleased
to be here today leah
thank you for having me yeah it's such a
pleasure i'm really excited to jump in i
have a
million and one questions but before we
do um i just want to let everybody know
that this
is sponsored by blockbuy and you can
actually get up to 250
when you sign up um i think you can get
around six percent interest which is
really cool so there's a link somewhere
for you so matthew you are the ceo of
sino global capital for those i don't
know to give us a brief picture as to
what you guys do sure so we invest
we as strategic investors in the best
blockchain projects
all around the world and the reason it's
a strategic check is we help
our portfolio companies here in mainland
china
which certainly as we've seen in the
last week or so
is arguably the most important market
in crypto and certainly among the major
markets
is the most esoteric and really
impenetrable for international projects
so basically we touch
four bases east west finance and
technology and we're pretty good across
those four bases
and we invest uh in crypto
but as more with a traditional vc
approach namely that we find people that
we think are awesome
that we want to hang out with for the
long term and we support them
uh here in china so we look for the best
people around the world people like uh
like ftt and serum and solana
people like sam bankman freed and
anatoly
from solana and we support them day in
day out here with boots on the ground in
china
i think um with everything that's going
on um
with china and over the last two weeks
it's such a fascinating place to be
based because
it's really hard to understand exactly
what is going on
and just how much the market is being
affected
so i i want to go through all of it
um i really don't fully have um
a hold on the situation so given you're
there
just to start with the absolute basics
what are the attitudes
like towards crypto
so i i think it's it's difficult to
answer questions like that because
really you have so many different
constituencies
so when you say added towards attitudes
towards crypto
you have a small number of people that
are engaging with crypto
in a sophisticated institutional way
you have a vast swath of people that are
engaging in a retail way
you have uh regulators uh you have
all kinds of different uh people with
all kinds of different views so i think
it's kind of tough
to to answer in that way um
the the best way really to answer it is
that
i mean how would you answer that for the
us you have some people think it's
you have some people
think it's the greatest thing ever and
they're tweeting about
doge or whatever you have some people
that are hot and cold like elon
you got all kinds of people so it's
really
similar in in that respect i would say
but if i if i looked at india for
example or nigeria i could sort of say a
clean you know okay well their
governments
are hostile towards it and that's really
obvious but
china it's really hard to understand
what's going on there's a lot of
flip-flopping
um you know every go on yagon
oh i'm sorry so if you narrow the
question to the chinese government then
that's
easier to answer so i would answer
thusly so the chinese government
uh views blockchain as a strategic
technology much in the way that they do
technology such as ai and 5g they view
it as
enormously important and that's why for
example they've been working on their
shoes that will be their digital
currency for years now and it's
finally uh on the on about to come to
fruition
um so that's blockchain though and as we
know blockchain is for sure not the same
thing
as crypto uh that's more distributed
ledger type thing it's not
pure crypto right so um conversely i
think that they're
kind of wary and not super comfortable
with crypto
because it engages and overlaps with
strategic technology blockchain in many
ways they don't quite want to just shut
it down entirely
but they're they're kind of wary of it
and i think that wariness explains
hot and cold behavior in in some ways
but stepping back from that i think that
um
one reason that it's quite difficult to
interpret there are several reasons but
one reason quite difficult to interpret
chinese government pronouncements is
that you need a lot of contextual
knowledge
and so part of that contextual knowledge
that i think is super important
in understanding the chinese government
action with respect to crypto
is you need to know where the the third
rails are the third rail is that that
electric rail that you can't touch
so the chinese government with respect
to crypto the first third rail
is that uh they're enormously sensitive
to anything
that interacts with the currency control
regime
uh as most people probably know the
renminbi is not a free floating currency
like the united states dollar
it's a strictly controlled currency and
so
anything that could potentially be an
end around
or weaken the currency control regime
that's a that's a third rail they're
enormously sensitive to that
so that's the first one uh the second
one then
is anything uh so the first two are
related the the
the second one then is uh fiat on and
off ramp
and anything related to aml
and tax evasion um
uh and then the third thing i would say
is
uh anything related to excessive retail
speculation
and so it's important to understand that
um there are a lot of
even before crypto and even now but
not related to crypto there's a lot of
uh mlm and ponzi type financial
schemes uh here in china called
tsujinpan
and um so these things uh can really
metastasize
metastasize overnight especially on a
regional
basis and so um what you can have
is you can have tens of thousands of
people in some
kind of random city that have all
invested in
a coin if you're lucky maybe
there's some actual value there but
probably there's not
so probably they're investing in some
ponzi coin
and it may be very regional and then
when it collapses you can suddenly have
thousands or even tens of thousands of
very pissed off people in a specific
place that are almost kind of like
mobilizing
and and you know potentially even
protesting and so the government is
enormously
sensitive to this kind of potential
retail and
investor unrest so i think when you
interpret
chinese government pronouncements one
reason it's it's so difficult
is you you have to understand what is
actually super important to them
and then kind of start on that basis i
think
so you just to go back a second you
mentioned fiat on and off ramps is it
difficult
for a retail investor to actually buy
bitcoin out there
so it that i i would say it like this
um there is enormous
creativity in um
in finding ways to to get done what you
want to get done
so people have uh by observation there's
an almost endlessly creative uh
solution space that people have in in
order to get in and out
but um it's it's something that's
enormously sensitive
frankly this is a topic that that we
know a lot less about because
we don't go anywhere near there i've
literally never
gone from fiat in or out to crypto ever
not even once uh wait i just wanna i
just
why not because this is something that's
very sensitive and so
i i like to sleep very peacefully
so cyno has literally never done that
ever
we never touched remy ever not
even ever so uh it's an area that the
point
though being that it's an area that we
know a little bit less about
because of that um but you know by
observation there is enormous energy
that
goes into finding end arounds for this
kind of thing
but it's it's a very uh at best it's a
gray area and it's a very
uh dangerous activity as we saw uh i
guess it was about a year ago
with a famous china ogee who who was
arrested for this type of activity it's
actually a bitfinex
uh shareholder um and and these things
definitely happen from time to time it's
not
something you you want to be involved
with but but people spend a lot of
energy
on this and they for sure do find ways
to do it
for sure but this is it's no change that
that's a sensitive
activity that's something that has been
the case for quite a long period of time
okay so would you then say operating
in china um in this industry is
difficult
because if we compare it to the uk where
i'm based right now
it's super easy it's so easy to buy
bitcoin it's
it everything is so you know
there's no threat or any concern or
anything like that
i think it kind of depends what you're
looking to do
so certainly um if you already have
money in crypto you are
free to currently free to uh
trade crypto uh if you already have
money in
in the crypto system so to speak as long
as you're compliant with aml
and and uh and tax and such
um and and and so you know ultimately it
depends what what you're looking to do
it it's definitely a more much more
complicated landscape
uh even for uh
you know native chinese or people that
are fully expert in the chinese market
um and and that's for sure for many
reasons one reason is that
um in the west we have uh
pretty much a black and white legal
landscape which is why another reason
why it's difficult for people understand
what's going on in china
uh in the uk or in the united states
it's kind of like
you have you know 30 percent of things
that are definitely illegal
and then you have 68 percent of things
that are definitely illegal and then you
have a gray area that's kind of like 2
in china it's more like you have
15 of things that are definitely illegal
and 40 of things that are definitely
legal and then you have a huge gray area
so that's a very different framework to
operate in
to have an enormous gray area
rather than you know a very a very black
and white landscape
uh that's another reason it's super
difficult for people to understand
um what's going on in china because you
have kind of what's on paper
in in the west i think that the overlap
between what's on paper and what's
actually taking place on the ground
is you know enormous it's a
huge overlap in china there's a
substantially uh the
the overlap is substantially less you
definitely
can't understand the landscape by just
looking at what's
on paper that will definitely get you
very confused very quickly uh so you you
have to have an understanding of two
things
number one what's on paper number two
facts on the ground and then the third
thing you also need to understand
how those two interact and how that
might change
over time so it's definitely uh
in a way more nuanced
yeah and i think i think the confusion
comes in because every single
bull market and you know we've seen over
the last few weeks there's always news
coming out
um of china that you know they've banned
this or they've stopped that so
and then also actually i think it was
about three weeks ago i made a video
because china actually
made gave the green light on something
bitcoin related
so then that's a bit of a flip-flop
there so how can the same news keep
coming out i think that's kind of what i
don't understand are they
they just re um reinforce a previous
um hostility from 2017 for example
so i would phrase it like this
um one way the chinese government
manages um
financial markets and including crypto
is that they use signaling
as a way to tamp down on excessive
speculative forces for example so
some uh so so
as the the market goes through a bowl
and bearing cycles in a bull cycle
we can expect that the chinese
government at some point
is likely to signal that things are
getting a little
too um
a little too frothy so
in that sense that that's something that
would be a repeated action
against across rather many years
uh so that's the first thing but just on
that point
nothing is actually changing it's merely
a signal
well i i think that
that is um i i think that that's too
simple of you in 2017 it's definitely
true
that there was a crackdown on ico
related activities
uh it's also definitely true that there
were counter responses uh
even to the point of
of small things such as uh people
know that they can't talk freely
probably about icos on wechat
so they start using little codes like
ic0 or whatever was one that was very
common
so um it's important to understand that
first that
people are enormously creative at
moving around with the
the central government based in beijing
may want
at any given time and that can
uh reveal itself in several aspects that
can reveal itself in the fact that
sometimes there's a disconnect
between uh the central government
and regional or local governments number
one
and number two that there's again these
creative solutions
uh to to uh moving around
government uh policy imperatives
and i'm trying to remember the
expression off the top of my head but
it's something like the
the mountains are high and the emperor
is far far away
something like that but uh you know the
point is that
what the central government base in
beijing wants to get done is not
always what will ultimately happen
uh there's also the expression uh
shangyou
shayo duisu which basically means that
there are there are
uh you know measures and then there are
counter measures so
in beijing they might want one thing and
then locally they they might find a way
to
get done what they want to get done
understood there's a lot of
complicated nuances yeah no i i get that
and i really appreciate you
breaking that down um it is so difficult
to fully understand what is going on
um because like you said what happens in
practice
isn't necessarily um doesn't necessarily
reflect
what's what's happening on paper um but
this week
there was um apparently in the news that
said
um a crackdown um on bitcoin miners in
beijing
so before we get into that how correct
is that
so i i think that's
uh i i would not phrase it that way i
would phrase it
as this so um
there was a routine policy meeting
related to financial stability
not specifically bitcoin not
specifically crypto but
overall financial stability
uh a routine meeting and as
part of that meeting there was a line
item
which was uh related specifically to
crypto
including bitcoin mining so i
i think first of all it's uh important
to understand that this is not a story
specifically about crypto it's a story
about
how the chinese government doesn't like
excessive
financial speculation especially retail
now it is true that that was a meeting
at the vice premier level and the vice
premier
is uh is the point person
for economic policy so it is true that
it's very serious in
in that regard but
i would view it as this is
an initial indication that the
government
is very closely studying these issues
and is uh evaluating
possible uh policies that could be
implemented
uh that's quite different than um
overnight bitcoin mining is banned
something like that yeah
um so there are a lot of open
questions such as is is this something
that
would be implemented at the national
level
is this something that would be
implemented at the provincial level what
would be the possible
scope for example are we talking about
bitcoin mining or are we talking about
unauthorized bitcoin mining because
that's two extremely different things
so there are a lot of open questions and
i i think
as a result it's very important to
use one's contextual knowledge of china
and evaluate
a range of possibilities and try to put
a probability on those
uh the fact is that uh when the chinese
government moves it frequently starts as
high-level
opaque policy pronouncements which are
very difficult to interpret that's kind
of where we are now
and then as time goes on you can start
with details around those so
that so therefore i think uh
a credible analysis would
say that there's a wide range of
potential outcomes and we're trying to
put probabilities
on those um it it's
much less or maybe even not credible if
we start to
see things saying uh bitcoin mining
banned bitcoin in china is
over you know something like that
doesn't make any sense to me
um so i would kind of suggest that
that's
a good way to look at it yeah it makes a
lot of sense and i feel like i
definitely have a better
grip now on the situation of
understanding how it works
um there are always these concerns
that bitcoin mining is centralized in
china before we get into what that could
mean
um i just wanted to know where you stand
on that
well so i i think
uh if is the question
uh am i concerned that uh
the region the country of china which is
also a region
am i concerned that there's so much uh
mining hash rate
in china not are you concerned
not are you concerned but do you think
that there is like a lot of people say
that it's centralized
um and then they say they're not that
actually for whatever reason that's not
actually a problem and like you said you
know
that's a true statement that there's a
lot of hash rate in china that's
definitely a true statement
in uh especially in um in sichuan and
xinjiang those two provinces there's uh
enormous
uh hash rate i mean that's a factual
statement
am i worried about that not really i
think
uh people make the assumption that these
are
actors that are all kind of on the same
page and could act like a cartel and
that
that's a risk factor in some way and i
uh i'm skeptical that it could ever work
that way
in practice you have a lot of disparate
actors with varied incentives
i think that it would be quite difficult
to get them
all on the same page to act
not only together but in a way that is
potentially against their own
economic incentives i'm i'm
quite skeptical of these narratives but
yeah sure it's a factual statement that
there's
huge hash rate in china that's true
well so you mentioned sichuan so sichuan
is one of the areas where
um there's a lot of renewable energy
so people are mining there just because
you know when there's a high supply
obviously the prices
for mining is lower so i want to talk
about energy everything that's been
going on
at the moment um of course you know elon
musk did that whole flip-flop
um one minute tesla are accepting
bitcoin the next minute they're not
accepting bitcoin
um so just not my favorite thing
yeah go on why what happened there for
you yeah
you know i i think look it's
crypto is a unique space right i mean i
myself
should post on twitter yeah probably
somewhat famously i like to pose
but i i also try to be
responsible about the way i do it
and so um
and and and i i think there's a way to
do things in a fun way
yeah and there's a way to do things in
an irresponsible way
and so uh even
you know a a crypto person like myself
is
is concerned about that and to have
elon musk who's what second
richest person in the world as of today
to be fundamentally in my view
irresponsible
i think it's incredibly disappointing i
think that um
um he's larping much of the time i mean
i do think he's interested in crypto he
thinks it's
fun and he's probably interested in it
for legitimate reasons as well
but um look he he can't make jokes about
tess buying tesla at 420 anymore so
he's finding a different way to larp and
i think it sucks honestly
i think it's i think it's um it
would be
irresponsible even for someone like me
and for the second richest person in the
world to be acting like that i think
it's
basically yeah i can really understand
the frustration
of people in the community especially
when you know people try
so hard for example like nick carter to
try and really explain
um how bitcoin can use renewable energy
and how it's actually
in that positive i think it's satoshi
him or her or myself
i think sorry interrupt i think we got
to be a little careful
because um i i think that
it's very um i mean we have our own
vested interests
right so uh many of us have most
of our net worth in crypto and we're
working in crypto full-time
but i think you have to be
intellectually honest also
and i don't claim to be a mining expert
there are many
other people who are uh
more understanding of mining than i am
that's not a primary focus at sino
however
uh i i think that um
we we should be my suggest i would let
me phrase it this way my suggestion is
that we need to be
intellectually honest and not act like
we're a bitcoin lobbying firm
trying to push a narrative so i think we
need to be super careful
about uh engaging with the bitcoin
as something environmentally friendly
narrative
in a way that speaks to the facts and is
intellectually honest
uh now i again i am not a foremost
mining expert by any stretch uh i'm a
a a china focused person but not with a
specific
mining uh competency but my
my observation for sure is that
uh some of these narratives feel
more like bitcoin big bitcoin lobbying
uh then something that is intellectually
honest that's my opinion yeah no i i
totally understand because i think you
know
saying that bitcoin is green energy or
use you know bitcoin is green
is definitely a stretch you know like
everything uses energy
i think the point that people have to
stress is that
well why don't we compare it to what we
currently have now
and sort of go from there and understand
whether it's better whether it's worth
it whether it is
greener not green but greener i think
maybe that's like a
sure a key point um i i fully
support that i fully support nuanced
discussions
about different kinds of trade-offs
i think that's something that's super
important
um or what i don't like is
pushing it a story is where i
i think it's helpful for even as someone
who is
full-time crypto and has a lot of
at stake along with the rest of us right
i don't think
it's the right thing i don't think it's
helpful for anyone
to push a story and not engage
with um with things in an intellectually
honest way
that that's my suggestion and i think
nuance is just impossible over twitter
um you know
if that's anything that i've learned it
is
twitter is not made twitter is not made
for debate i will i can debate that
for ages yeah i mean look obviously
i think we all know that i love twitter
probably way too much
but um i i definitely agree with that
it's very very difficult to have nuance
on twitter look obviously right
but you can also have things that are
clearly like a way of going
about your business
where it's just you're just talking
nonsense
and you're you're just um um
you know lobbying or
you know fun but but and so i don't
really mind posting but then when
when people are pushing
uh simplistic you know almost even
intellectually dishonest narratives
that's different shitposting i think of
this just like
maybe that's not what people mean when
they say that but to me i think of it
as like uh fun talking trash
type type thing to me that's okay
but what's not okay is trying to
uh twist
twist the reality of our industry
yeah i understand and i think i think
talking about intellectual honesty
so important um and that nuance is
really important
um but off the back of all of this the
mighty bitcoin
council came about so that was all very
exciting
um this caused a lot of backlash um
and it it was really polarizing
so before i give my views what are your
views
on a bitcoin council put together
by two billionaires
i'm not super i don't have strong
feelings on this one i'm not
okay opposed to it um
i i mean i i think in general i'm
someone that
gets very worked up about
monopoly power and things like that um
at the same time uh i'm not opposed to
different stakeholders working together
uh if they are truly trying to
uh you know make improvements and and be
pro-social i i i don't necessarily have
strong feelings on it at this time
i i think it comes down to intent
and i think that's an open question
but but i think then again you know i'm
not like
i i'm more of a candidly i'm more of a
post-etherium d5 kind of guy
i'm not really like the old-school
austrian economics libertarian type if i
were i would probably
be furious about bitcoin mining council
but that's not really
me understood i think it's
the idea of having this trustless
network
where there's no centralized power and
we all have
one incentive which is basically make
money
pay back those mining um fees
those those energy costs so
i i can fully understand the frustration
i mean
for me personally i am there's i want to
say a die hard libertarian but i really
my heart really feels the the pull
towards
um not having centralized power but
that's interesting though so
did you we were you that libertarian and
then you moved and sort of
moved more towards when i was when i was
like 19
okay usually it's the other way around
usually
usually when you're younger sorry go on
i went through i'm randy and phase i did
i read all
i read every single one of iran's books
when i was like
17 18 19.
i i definitely went through that phase
at one point
but usually it's when you're younger so
when i was about six
years ago you get more conservative when
you get older but i'm not sure
conservative is the same thing as
libertarian and i certainly would argue
that you're not
but it's not uh i do think that to some
extent libertarian
is i mean a lot of people go through a
libertarian phase in their late teens
and early twenties don't don't they
when they other way around yet
no no way i totally disagree with you i
think
socialism when you're young socialists
in your 20s
you know when nobody's working and
they're not paying their own bills
they're happy for socialism when you
start making your own money and you're
paying your own bills
and you're working hard to pay those
bills
you then lean a bit more to
libertarianism i would say
could be could be you're you're in the
uk though right
you guys are still pretty normal well
you got brexit but
but the united states has taken a weird
lurch
over my lifetime so my
my politics have stayed basically the
same
but i went from like uh
probably like uh i i went from
maybe a
republican voter to uh to you know to
abide in type guy
even though my politics have basically
stayed the same
but i i can see from your facial
expression we're probably not going to
find a lot of common ground here
no i i don't like biden if i could
if i could fit in really nicely in in
america it would be somewhere in texas
or florida
that just that's me christ are you
are you sure oh i'm totally sure i'm
totally sure
i can i can
or texas would you go would you go to
miami
or would you go like completely nuts and
go like the florida
panhandle i don't know what that is um
but miami that's where it gets really
weird oh really what happens there
uh i i think that's where it it's more
um but miami's
miami is a modern city right yeah so you
can
i i think i also would love miami in
many ways in austin
we we have uh uh we have um
we have uh uh our dj and fund manager
lives in miami
we have an internal djing fund run by
uh a kid brilliant kid he's
still
how old is he what's a kid how old is he
i think he's
i think he's 22. damn that is what he's
meant
but he's been in d5 for you know like
three years now and he's been in crypto
for like five years
and he's an absolute stud anyway
he lives in miami
no i love that i think the whole what
like this this is why
i don't care about i i don't care about
uh you know aids or pedigree or any of
this i don't give a we we
turned down
uh you know harvard zuma
kamladi grads all the time i don't give
a about any i just care about
uh hustle and industry knowledge and
uh ability to get cool done
uh so i i would hire a 62 year old or 22
year old or a 17 year old or
i don't give a but yeah we so we
have a kid
a kid that manages our internal dji fund
and he does an absolutely
fantastic job he's just a complete stud
where did you find him where did you
find him
he cold-called us as a recall i really
said in my
twitter dms there you go and we we on
the regular
interview hundreds of people to find one
guy
or girl and and he he
he uh so he came on as an intern and
he's just a animal
so we hired him and now he manages money
and he's
in fact he managed money before he even
graduated university
so he still had some classes left it was
his last semester
and so he was sitting in class
managing money
well always uh you know ignoring the
professor probably
and he is just absolute absolute stunt
yeah i think the entire world is
changing something that i always say is
that
um university eventually will become
redundant for most subjects um
and for some reason that upsets a lot of
people but but it is what it is and i
think that
um you know he he messaged you he
messaged you on twitter twitter is
where where it's at when it comes to
networking um
and i love it a lot of people get
offended
when i say that university is something
of the past for most
degrees i mean i regret my degree i did
a journalism degree
um worked as a journalist didn't like it
now i do more info informal journalism i
guess you could call this girl i think
journalism is cool
depends how you do it in another
lifetime i could totally be in it like
an
investigative journalist i think
journalism is awesome
yeah when you do it for yourself it is
of course it is i love look like i
i the reason why i did the show today
with you is because i didn't understand
what's going on in china i want to
understand what's going on in china i
speak to somebody on the ground like
that's that's journalism right so i love
that but not when you
um like worked for work for a big
organization
exactly that's what i'm saying that's
two different things
actually having a job in journalism
sounds honestly terrible
but the actual work of being an
investigative journalism sounds just
awesome
yeah i have a story for you so i used to
work
for um do you know cgtn you must know
them china's global tv
mostly i used to work
hard yes i used to work for them
um a television
global division okay yes
yeah yeah so i worked basically directly
for the for them
um and i was based out in paris um
and i was sort of providing the european
perspective as to
what's going on anyway there was a
huawei 5g conference
um and i was working there and i had to
i may not be able to comment on this you
know you don't have to comment you
honestly oh i'm like
i may just listen that's it yeah yeah
yeah little film
okay so i was um so i was at the
conference it was a huawei 5g conference
and um i was basically covering
putting together a news package multiple
different types of um
creative pieces for cgtn
and um i was under strict instructions
about certain things that i couldn't
do so i uh i
ask a lot of questions because i just
want to understand
um i might ask the same question several
times i just really want to understand
something
um so for me and i'm very direct in the
way that i speak so for me
i just wanted to know from this guy that
i was interviewing
so what are your comments about america
for example
blacklisting huawei and you know you're
potentially doing the same thing
i wasn't allowed to ask that i wasn't
allowed
and because i wasn't based in china i
was based in
europe it was really hard to wrap my
head around
the fact that i'm producing a new story
and i'm not allowed to ask a really
good simple obvious question so
you know you're you're talking about 5g
you're talking about huawei today there
are concerns that europe might follow
i follow america how do you feel about
that i wasn't allowed
but i'm not convinced that's so
different
this is not a defense of cgtn by the way
it's a critique of american media is
what it is
so i want to be clear on that point i'm
not convinced that's
so different than fox news or sinclair
which is a network of news stations in
the united states i'm not convinced it's
totally
different from that well i mean i don't
think that i would be in trouble if i
ask those questions in america
and when i was told
you know basically you would you could
lose your job i think
i can't comment on that they don't know
but what i do know is that i was told to
make a fluff piece
not a serious news piece that's what i
was yeah i
i'm sure i'm sure i'm not convinced that
from fox news or sinclair is my boy
maybe i
i don't know but i i don't know but i
was i was
it was interesting and then at the
conference as well when i interviewed
the guy
um there was just so much security
watching the interview
yeah yeah no government official
anything like that just
somebody at huawei um
and yeah all eyes all eyes while the
interview was happening
and i was like wow this is it's strange
it was a really weird experience um but
since you um at cena global capital
um since you guys specialize
in um finding those hidden gems i think
that's what i read on your website
you called them hidden we we also invest
in super high profile companies and
projects like uh
you know ftp and solana in serum
but um i i kind of
view um
the real job or the real talent of
a vc is is um
is finding
uh talent and opportunities in
unexpected places
uh so for sure we we do both but
maybe i guess i like underdogs so my my
heart is maybe
in the gems maybe you could you could
think of it that way that way maybe
can you tell us i like underdogs and
outsiders
like who oh well i mean just like a
general comment
you know okay so you're
obviously interested
no no you go for it go for it well i
mean
i don't know it's it's more fun to find
some random
genius in lisbon than it
is to find
a third generation stanford grad backed
by sequoia
isn't it like more fun i think it's more
fun
you know i mean look what we do both you
know
but my heart my heart i'm more
passionate about finding the people that
fail pattern matching but they're
awesome
you know pattern species have their
pattern matching
right and so they look for
uh you know a small certainly silicon
valley dc's
would rather see a stanford drop
out than than the the best student in
the last 10 years at purdue you know
so i'd rather look for people that fail
traditional pattern matching tests but
they're awesome
and i'd rather invest in them and then i
have 1.4 billion people i can introduce
them to
and we can try to make some things
happen so i
you know i i we look we do both but i
might i know where my heart is
you know
no i get that i get one it's far more
rewarding um but just finally
i'm interested to hear um why you're
excited about solana
so uh i think that um it's about
design space and so
um we also are enormously bullish on
ethereum
ethereum is amazing colic is a
goddamn legend
so ethereum right now is kind of like
the default in many ways for d5 right
it's your everyday car and it's a
great car
would be super comfortable comfortable
recommending this car
to anyone so um
now if this is your everyday car i don't
know what's a good everyday car i don't
know a volvo i don't know
so if this is your volvo which is a safe
car it's a dependable car it's a good
everyday car
um super comfortable recommending it but
there's a limited
space of things you can do with a volvo
uh
so solana on the other hand is like your
weekend car
and it's a goddamn ferrari this
is your performance car
so um a performance car opens up
a whole vast design space by which i
mean
all sorts of new applications all sorts
of new things that you can do
so solana has a fundamentally
um different uh
transaction cost and transaction speed
it's uh you know one or two orders of
magnitude
uh faster and cheaper to be using the
solana ferrari
versus the ethereum volvo which i also
again love because it's it's a
great car
um so especially solana i think will be
super well suited for fintech
decentralized fintech applications uh
that have
high performance needs which is why you
see
um jump trading i'm not sure
how widely known jump trading is because
it's
uh elite in the same sense as goldman
sachs but they're not public facing so
many people don't know what trump
trading is
but basically for tradfy jump trading is
one of the very most elite
trading firms in the world on the
caliber as
jane street if you probably haven't
heard of jane street either
because again not public facing they
just trade their own capital and they
have no need for people to know who they
are
but that's where sam bankman freed came
from he went from mit to jane street
to to to alameda and ftx so
anyway the point is that that's why jump
trading which is now
um spending an enormous amount of
time on five they have uh
they have two partners that manage the
firm and one of the two
partners is personally managing it
managing d5
efforts and he and they have uh you know
at this point dozens of people focused
on d5
uh and they are very focused on solana
uh and serum because of its unique
suitability for d5
uh for high performance d5 in fact
they're launching a
uh a new project soon it's called pith
which is being spun out of uh of jump
trading it's an
in it's a uh it's an oracle
related project but anyway the point is
that
um uh solana opens up and serum opens up
a whole new design space
uh because that kind of transaction
speed
and cost is is so fundamentally
important
um in in finance so i think we will also
have
other interesting applications come out
of this new vast design space that's
only the first one
and they may be very unrelated to d5 in
fact i i believe we will see
people experimenting with some of these
ideas
that were premature and ultimately
disastrous in 2017 a lot of times timing
is
is is so important so i believe uh now
that we have solana people
will revisit ideas such as decentralized
social networks decentralized you know
twitter
things like that and they might have uh
a much higher chance of success
versus in 2017 when when we got these
projects we
we basically were like this is
ridiculous this is this is a stupid idea
but now they might actually make sense
um
so uh basically it's about that design
space and it's about
if you have something that's ten
thousand times faster and ten thousand
times
times cheaper all of a sudden you can do
so many cool things
and i i'm not even i don't think anyone
knows what some of these things will be
yet but there's definitely going to be
amazing
creativity coming out of this new design
space so we were
even though we we are sitting on an
enormous stack of ethereum and are
hugely bullish on ethereum
we're just so excited about solana and
serum
yeah i think what we're at a stage now
where you're absolutely right
it's all about timing um i even think
politically
we've seen um we've had a lot of
hostility
um towards our space online um which
kind of creates the need and pushes the
need more for
these decentralized applications web 3
and all of it so no i'm totally with you
i think it's really exciting um
i hold some soul that's why i asked you
um so yeah i'm excited
i guess you're gonna make it gmi i hope
i make it
i hope i make it i don't know we'll have
to see um
but matthew i want to thank you so much
for coming on i almost forgot i promised
i would
give a shout out to my friends
the lunatics at uh cope which is a sino
project
and they have one of the most intense
amazing communities and i love
them so much and so i promised i would
give a shout out to the cope
ape army my my lunatic friends
at cope i promised i would do that so
thank you there you go
no that's absolutely fine matthew i want
to thank you so much wait hold on
where's your where's your where's your
coke
where's i don't have any i don't have
any well you have to have a copy
i don't know what that is what's a copy
so cope
is a solana based project
it's a dyno portfolio company
and so we really love the community
and we thought a fun thing would be for
for the big cup holders for every one of
them
we adopted an actual ape
you adopted an ape yeah we adopted like
12 apes they're in rwanda
so you should get a name that's my point
we adopted like really they're in rwanda
being taken care of by an environmental
conservation group
so it's just something for you to think
about i will think about it thank you
for sharing that's actually really
interesting
um i'll have to find out more
information on that but wait matthew
before we go
where can people where can people find
you where can people
follow you and see what you're up to so
the easiest
ways to find me are on either uh twitter
or wechat
um so for my my twitter
is maddie sino and the sino global
twitter i guess it's sino global
cap cap that's the easiest way to find
me
there you go i thank you so much it's
been really good
honestly i've been wanting to learn more
and understand more about what's going
on um
where you are so yeah i really
appreciate um you speaking on it and
i enjoyed how you spoke around the
subject i thought that was
entertaining so
i enjoyed it as well thanks absolutely
so everyone thank you for tuning in
and we will see you next week bye bye
okay
[Music]
[Applause]